if I may there's this it's probably an
apocryphal story but there was a story
that I heard from an old character actor
there was a there were two young actors
that were sitting at the commissariat
Warner Brothers and one was talking to
the other about I don't know if I should
take this job I don't know if it's good
for my career you know I look at it and
I think well there's you know this is
but I don't really know if it's good for
my career and there was an old character
actor sitting at the table next to him
and he leaned over excuse me guys I
don't really do this but if I might just
say you don't have a career you have a
job and you'll get another job and then
you try to get another job and then a
job after that and you keep doing that
and then at the end of it you look back
on a career and and that hit me I mean I
have a career now but it's in retrospect
I'm still going about getting that job
let's get that job let's solve that
problem let's find that character let's
see what we can contribute where can we
take some of the weight off of the guy's
having to carry this film on his
shoulders that's my job and I hope they
keep hiring me because I like that job
you